[Music]
lower your voice holy [ __ ]
are her breasts real yes why is this
[ __ ] switch not working
what's wrong with my life don't shoot
the hostages
protect the hostages charlie we gotta
protect
that science on the board i can't read
it it's ps1 maybe if this was
i forgot how to pick stuff up i just
remembered i was saying something funny
earlier i was telling about all the
weirdest thing doc ock's ever done
okay one time uh he got the sinister six
together and said he was gonna put a
chemical in the atmosphere that would
kill society base it's gonna put like
this like chemical weapon into the uh
satellite that was being launched right
as the sinister six pointed out a
horrible plan
you can't hold the planet for ransom and
then it gets up there and then the gas
disperses after
he wins like the gas gets up there and
spider-man's like oh no the world is
destroyed
and then he's like wait we all breathed
in the gas everything's fine what's
going on doc ock and he's like
well now all of you are allergic to
cocaine can't
snort it or whatever without just
going into violent convulsions and he's
like i have the antidote or if you want
more cocaine hit me up and like every
crime boss ever was like holy [ __ ]
we'll buy your antidote mr doc off we
can't live without our coke
and then because that gas was up there
he ripped a hole in the ozone layer and
he had to undo it
[Music]
you